en python podemos hacer la suma de 2 números
de una forma fácil y rápida
lo primero que vamos a hacer es solicitar
un dato y asignarlo a una variable
en ese caso la variable n uno
mediante int
vamos a especificar qué es un valor de tipo entero
mediante input
vamos a especificar que vamos a solicitar un valor
dentro de los paréntesis de nuestro input
vamos a colocar aquí número uno
y lo mismo hacemos
para la variable n 2 tipo entero
necesitamos un valor número 2
posteriormente
hacemos la operación en una nueva variable n uno
más n 2 de esta forma en la variable x
ya tendríamos el resultado de la suma
solo faltaría mostrar el resultado de la suma
haciendo uso de print
y la variable x
procedemos a ejecutar nuestro programa
nos va a solicitar el número uno
el número 2 y finalmente vamos a tener
una suma en python de una forma fácil y rápida
sígueme para más videos de python